[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
welcome to piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle tonight
nhs national health service or never
here soon as horror stories about
ambulance waiting times continue we'll
speak to those on the front line 25
years have passed and even more
conspiracies have been aired since the
death of princess diana but it's the
simple truth my friends she was murdered
by the press and we'll meet the woman
who opened the doors to ukrainian only
to watch the refugee walk out them 10
days later with the father of her kids
she joins me live
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends now you weren't
seriously expecting to see piers morgan
here on a bank holiday monday were you
out of your tiny minds as the old saying
goes when the cat's in san tropez the
mice will play so here we are struggling
through another week before the big guy
that's what it says here returns next
monday we wrote this pm is back for the
new pm on the 5th of september uh listen
morgan's absence aside there aren't many
signs of this being a bank holiday out
there you know granted you might have
noticed hardly anyone's at work today
maybe that the trains are running on a
reduced schedule or that no post came
through your letterbox this morning
nothing new you might say there but
there will be a fresh pm a week today
and one thing the new incumbent will
have to tackle seriously is the nhs
aging chronically ill with no real
chance of further life expectancy these
are just some of the things our health
service has in common with many of its
frequent flyers right now according
today to matthew taylor chief executive
the nhs confederation the new prime
minister will inherit inherit an nhs in
its worst state in living memory look at
this there are currently 105 000
vacancies in the uk in the nhs add to
that a further 165
000 in the social care sector and if you
are lucky enough to spot a doctor in the
building don't put the sudoku book down
yet because the number of people waiting
in a e
more than 12 hours has increased
fivefold in the past year now if you do
get admitted which is fantastic your
care is then at risk due to the
relentless under investment in aged
crumbling buildings and of course if
that roof falls in whilst you're gazing
in the mirror thinking i look quite good
in this hospital gown you'll probably
then be put on a waiting list of
following up following
6.5 million people right you'd have to
be in that queue that's a hundred times
more than we're at wembley for england
italy last summer on top of it all just
to make you feel really happy on a bank
holiday doctors are talking about going
on strike in the autumn they would like
at least if they are on a picket line
you might be able to see one in person
on talk tv the fact remains right if i
had a funny turn right now and this
production team lovely people
begrudgingly called an ambulance there
is a one in 10 chance that julia hartley
brewer would be here stepping over my
cold gasping body on the way to do the
breakfast show because it wouldn't have
arrived in about 10 hours one lady i
really believe this spoke for all of us
the whole of the nation last week when
she sort of ambushed the health
secretary steve barkley watch this
uh that plan for jobs has protected are
you gonna do anything about the
ambulances waiting and the people dying
out well don't you think 12 years is
long enough
yes and we are 12 years you don't bugger
all about it people have died and all
you've done is nothing
pretty clear-cut we're joined now by
mike padgeam chair of the independent
care group which uh runs five care homes
in scarborough but with me first in the
studio gp dr philippa k phillica welcome
back i i
we talked off air
people will tune into discussions about
the nhs they will hear stories about we
need more investment we need this we
need that
you're on the front line
just just just don't dress this up how
bad is it i think that everybody sees
when they see pictures in the media of
relatives putting up shelters over their
loved ones whilst they're waiting for
ambulances and nurses coming out in a e
saying you're going to be here even when
my shift is finished to know how serious
it is it is extraordinarily difficult
right now heading into winter
with covid and when we look at australia
for example australia have had a really
difficult flu season this year the worst
flu season for ages we tend to follow
them so we know that we're heading into
winter
plus you have to add in the cost of
living crisis and how that impacts
health which then impacts the nhs this
is incredibly serious we have to balance
that though with the fact that the nhs
is open a e is open for accidents and
emergencies go on do your bit i love
if you've had a cough or a cold don't go
to the hospital it's not the best place
to go we need to be using the nhs
appropriately so that is using your
pharmacist using 111 using walking
centers using your gps and a e for
excellent emergency okay
the thing is i get i absolutely get that
and the morale on the front line must be
dreadful and i fully understand the last
thing you want to do is sit here and say
it's that dar because you want people to
know but what we need is an honest
appraisal when you read as you said of
12 hours waiting to see an a e doctor
waiting 16 hours for an ambulance
when you say try one one one which i had
an experience of several months ago and
it was appalling the bloke was quite
patently reading off a cue sheet i've
said that before we waited eight hours
for an ambulance what hope can you give
people without dissecting we know the
people that work in the nhs are
fantastic they care but for british
people watching this all over the united
kingdom tonight
really really worried about money and
the cost of living if they get ill they
can't get through to get a gp they
struggle to get to hospital in an
ambulance and when they get there
they're left why have we got to this in
your mind why is it so bad is it money
or not and it's a combination of things
i think it's long long long term lack of
investment plus a pandemic plus two
years of everybody not having any
there's no no one's got their batteries
charged anymore there's no more goodwill
anymore people can't wait anymore and
all of that is coming together to sort
of it's like shaking the coke bottle and
then everything exciting nhs get it
wrong you know when people say to me we
need more money more money more money
what would be a a justifiable criticism
of the way the nhs a lot of people would
say this don't spend the money on the
things that are needed which are doctors
and nurses and ambulances and hospital
beds they send they spend it on
computers and brainstorming sessions and
diversity people they do that's a fact
how do we change that i think that it's
not that we need to change
lots of different things at the same
time and there isn't necessarily the
budget to do that and so what happens is
that you pay for the cracks and that
doesn't necessarily solve the problem in
the long term but what i would say to
the people who are watching scared about
what's going to happen this winter is
first of all what can you do and what
you can do is get your covert booster
when it comes in get your flu vaccine if
you live in london make sure your kids
got their polio vaccine you know there
are things that you can do attend your
screening because prevention is better
than cure and when people say oh you
know well the cost of living what should
i do with regards to should i have my
prescription medication and these are
choices that people are making that if
their prescriptions aren't free that
there are still people who cannot
necessarily afford to have that
medication how about that in 2022 people
having to make that decision eat or eat
your phone
or get a prescription because they
haven't got the money and even last
winter i was sitting on the phone in my
surgery telling people about the local
food banks telling people to go to the
library after school because essentially
that was almost like a heating bank that
your kids could do their homework and
somewhere where it was light and it was
warm and that was last winter and
poverty is associated with poor physical
and poor mental health outcomes which
then cost the nhs more and so we need to
look at things very globally not just
solely within health i really agree with
you with john now by my pageant chair of
the independent care group as i said
which runs uh five care homes across uh
scarborough uh mike welcome to the show
um i have a sort of vested interest in
this subject my father was in a care
home for months before he died actually
when kovid finished and he came out and
i will start by saying i think that the
social care issue is as big an issue as
the nhs and and certainly in terms of
the elderly this winter real fear tell
us the reality on the ground in care
homes as we approach in the nhs's words
dreadful times but for for care homes
dire as well right
yes i mean the the pandemic has been
dreadful for us as you mentioned the
vacancies in the nhs we've got 165 000
vacancies in social care and that's
growing and we need to recruit more
people in so we can actually help the
health service because if we're not
careful we're going to find care homes
closing and losing beds and also people
who look after care people in their own
homes also going out of business so it's
a real crisis in the 33 years i've been
involved it's worst i've ever known and
we want this government and the next
prime minister to get a grip on social
care to solve the problems once and for
all what are the answers we know that
the winter is coming we know the energy
bills of what gone from 1270 good in
january to potentially 5 000 next
january with i mean families left right
and center who will literally
be having to make the choices you talked
about do we get rid of this do we not do
that horrible horrible choices
for the elderly people who have worked
all their life paid their their stamp as
my old man used to say
what's the future like for them in care
well it's very difficult for you sure i
think the problem is as a country we
never fix a social care problem when we
were better off now we've got a crisis
it's it's a very difficult time to sort
it what i would say is more of the money
has to be put into social care so people
can be discharged out of the hospital
into their own homes or into calms to
free up the beds for those waiting for
treatment that's the way we should be
doing it the problem is of course um
people want tax cuts now that is not the
right way to go forward we need to be
spending more on social care and we need
to pay staff in social care a decent
wage at least on a par with the nhs is
that not both of you just appalling what
you just said we need to get more people
out of hospitals right out of the beds
to free them up they sent enough old
people back home to care homes during
covey didn't they fill up but without so
much as a backwood glance
and you also have to remember the number
of people who are looked after by
informal carers this country is run
by volunteers essentially the number of
people who wait for their loved one to
come off to work to drive 20 miles to
give them a cooked meal and now they
can't afford the petrol to get there and
all of that is going to have a real
impact mike do we need to be paying the
care industry workers you talked about
165 000 vacancies and one thing that i
got to know massively during my dad's
time in the care home was a lot of
people from from other countries working
for not particularly good monies and
then we get back to the whole debate do
we need to be offering more is it the
standard of living you know i i get
riled up and people will disagree but i
get riled up when you know i hear a
train driver on 59 000 pounds once the
pay rise because he hasn't had one for
three years or her and yet care workers
are probably on 12 or 14 grand a year in
the most awful circumstances and are
basically saving people's lives we get
it wrong in this country don't we
yes i think it's a big debate we need to
look at where how we value social care
and health really i don't really want to
comment on what the train drivers might
earned except to say social care staff
deserve more that means we've got to pay
them more which means funding local
authorities more at a time when the
country has run out of money but i think
social care has never been a priority
through all the political parties now is
the time to do something about it but
we're in this hiatus aren't we between
one government coming and a new pm
coming in next week is we want them to
be bold
i personally want to see the nhs and
social care merge to one and a national
pay rate for a care staff around about
15 pound an hour mark is a minimum we
could do that we could solve the problem
quite quickly but we've seen there's a
lot of talking and very little action
and that's the point that i said to you
phillip at the beginning we seem to have
heard about the problems with the nhs
and uh lately social care but we should
have been talking mike's absolutely
right we should have been talking about
social care years and years ago
we can talk about the pandemic we can
talk about you know the ukrainian war
and the cost of fuel but this winter is
terrifying for many many people old
people and people across the united
kingdom what is what is the next prime
minister we're not allowed to say it'll
be lose trust because obviously there
hasn't been an election yet that's what
all the polls say it could be rishi
sunak um whoever it is has got a big job
on us what do they need to do to cure
the in your mind brief the nhs problems
and the social care problems is it just
money or is it more i think they need to
look at the short term and the long term
together so we need a short-term fix for
recruitment right now in order to fill
those vacancies but we also need to be
looking at university training more
doctors training more nurses and i think
that that's true across each area within
the nhs and social care what can we do
now but what plans can you be putting
into place in order to ensure this thing
which is essential to the health
literally of this country um mike to
finish with you um i think philip has
absolutely spot on what amazes me and
you talked about a new government you
know next week
um there seems to be such little
foresight in government everybody says
well we knew this was coming you know it
was good nobody seems to have had a plan
we never seem to to to think beyond the
end of whenever in your mind 30 seconds
what does the new prime minister have to
do
they've got to put social care close to
the top of the list they've got to fund
it properly and it can be done quickly
if in my view they listen to the experts
already in the sector
be bold as knight bevin was in 1948 when
he set the health service up be bold get
health and social care together fund it
properly we don't need tax cuts i know
people need help with the cost of living
but funding in social care is absolutely
important because people deserve a
better quality of life as they get older
mike pagan thank you very much indeed dr
philippe as well the point is we're in a
situation in this country where
everybody is looking at where the next
pound comes from and of course we want
better education we want better
hospitals we want better doctors we want
better dentists we want cheaper petrol
we we want so much and it seems that
this is perfect storm it's all come at
once we will keep i promise you talking
about this on uncensored uh but coming
back next wednesday of course marks 25
years since the death of princess diana
now throughout her life
via an omission she used the media and
they used her but the big question as we
go towards wendy is was the press
responsible for her death what are your
thoughts we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now
throughout this week we'll look back at
princess diana her widespread legacy and
consider what she would make of today's
royal family tonight though i want to
start by examining the role of the press
in her life and ultimately in her death
her brother l spencer was pretty clear
of their responsibility for that fateful
car crash back in 1997.
it would appear that every proprietor
and editor of every publication that has
paid for intrusive and exploitative
photographs of her encouraging greedy
and ruthless individuals to risk
everything in pursuit of diana's image
has blood on his hands today
i'm now joined by former royal editor of
son duncan larkham former spokesman for
the fired family michael cole and jesus
journos uh tv presenter talk to you
president mike graham and political
journalist ava santina i'm going to
start with you duncan um everybody knows
my uh belief in the royal family and the
fact that my father worked for a long
long time for the queen mother um
el spencer they're saying that every
royal editor every editor of every
tabloid newspaper every newspaper has
blood on their hands tell me what you
made of the whole diana or the tragedy
of diana
actually for me it was my first week as
a journalist and it was my first time
out of the office on the local paper
going to do a vox pop on the people that
been to kensington palace and i was told
in no uncertain terms that i'd managed
to murder diana in my first five days of
my new career but honestly i mean i
think the press contributed
um lots of things contributed i spent
six months sitting through the inquest
at the high court and you know what was
quite clear is that it was a series of
absolutely tragic things that combined
why was there no crash barrier on the
pillars why did um diana's why was diana
in the hands of of our fired security
team that were chase most photographed
woman in the world
escaping being pictured when she'd
already been pictured with dodie so
you can blame the press the public have
and we've felt that
the death of diana changed the press i
don't doubt that exactly but whether or
not the press has got blood on their
hands i think a lot of people have got
blood on their hands frankly michael
cole if i can bring you in former bbc
royal correspondent and spokesman the
for the fired family take up duncan's
point there um were the people not
looking after her whether that was fired
security on her with were they not
responsible should they not have done
more for her instead of putting her in
that position
i think the inescapable fact is
that none of this would have happened
this terrible tragedy wouldn't have
happened nearly 25 years ago
had they not been pursued throughout the
day from the moment they arrived in
paris until the moment of the crash in
the tunnel and even
at that moment there were photographers
there
taking photographs of her
in her agony with internal injuries that
she was not going to survive
and one of them a frenchman called roman
rat
put his hands on her
and said help is coming with his other
hand he was taking pictures
and those pictures were sent to
publications in this country and no
respectable publication around the world
would touch them and i happen to know
that british newspapers british editors
were extremely relieved that there were
no british photographers there because
whoever
whatever caused this at the end of the
day
they were responsible in the sense that
they had as her brother charles said in
his eulogy
diana
the huntress in classical mythology
became diana the hunted and she was
hunted to her death that wouldn't have
happened if they'd been allowed to go
about their lawful business they
couldn't even go out to dinner
yeah i was actually working in fleet
street at the time and michael cole uh
remarkably forgets to blame muhammad
al-fayed who employed a pilled popped up
chauffeur who'd been drinking taking uh
drugs which were affecting his uh his uh
ability to see properly he was driving a
mercedes car which had been in a
previous accident had been chopped up
and put back together again so muhammad
al fired he might argue has blood on his
hands for hiring such a guy also martin
bashir may have blood on his hands
because if it wasn't for him she would
not have got rid of the royal security
that would have protected her and it's
nonsense to say that she was hunted
because that was her life and she had
been protected by the royal family for a
very very long time she decided not to
be protected by them it's quite
interesting over if i can bring you in i
said in the introduction and again i go
back to my old man
he always said to me that the the the
royal family changed after the queen
mother died the mystique went because
they all
at times apart from the queen
systematically have used the press to
their own advantage that is not a reason
to say there is no responsibility i
think it's a i think it's easy to say
the press were responsible in their
entirety what's your view i hate hearing
that i think you know if you if you take
away the cameras it was pretty much you
know a lot of old men chasing her for
the majority of her life since she was
about 19. you know to your point duncan
your first week in pr working in press
you were
working on this i was actually at
grenfell that was my first day in and
you know my editor wanted stories and i
could have really antagonized those
people outside i didn't approach anyone
i still delivered the story i would have
never ever attacked anyone the way that
i think diana was she was never attacked
though diana knew what the game was no
she was not i worked during those years
i know all of the people that were royal
correspondents during that time she was
not in any way attacked she used to get
in touch with people you might remember
the famous picture of her sitting on the
end of the yacht that didn't get taken
by accident he got taken because she
told them where she was going to be when
she was going to be there she was very
happy because it was antagonizing
charles who was her ex-husband they were
all british journalists were always
interested they did both he used the
british church
always at a safe distance and the
trouble is that if you are in the public
eye you need to be protected diana was
not protected but michael cole's um
ex-employer is responsible for that
michael let's bring you back in strong
words from mike graham what's your
response
terrible excuses
and
sophistication that isn't called for at
this particular time i revert to what a
jury of 11 ordinary londoners decided
they decided
yes it was not an accident it was
unlawful killing
caused by
absolutely represented and still defend
and you haven't answered what we both
well everybody's asked you does muhammad
al fire because he provided the people
that were looking after down on that
does he not share some responsibility as
well
he lost his son and he lost a very dear
friend
and he spent 10 years trying to find out
the truth of it all
henri paul i knew onrepaul he drove me
around in paris
he had been on two courses with
mercedes-benz
he had passed a
medical for his private pilot's license
the day before
he drank two glasses of parmesan
let me can i can i just ask a question
there so you're saying that the fact
that when diana got rid of her
bodyguards met police officers in 1995
met police officers do not chase and
play cat and mouse and run away from the
press because that is not their job
their job is her safety she got rid of
them on the night she died as tragic
though it is
she died because she was in the care of
people that did not properly look after
her now i agree and i will accept to
someone that used to work as royal
editor of the sun that the media did
create an environment as did the public
that meant those pictures were worth a
fortune that's why the guys would chase
him i'm not saying that's right or wrong
but do you accept at all
that she should have been better
protected on that night i mean okay the
press we were partly responsible was
muhammad al fired staff
no he wasn't responsible
because that that what happened would
not have happened had they not been
pursued and harassed throughout the
whole day they were there everywhere
they went and you're everywhere and you
know
and you know duncan
because you were the royal editor of the
sun but the reason that diana dispensed
with her scotland yard detectives was
that she believed quite rightly that
they were reporting back on who she was
seeing where she was going because
martin beshear told her
that that was happening it was martin
bashir who lied a proven liar yeah from
the bbc who forged documents who worked
for the same mob i mean you've got
pretty bad record here son you work for
the bbc who faked documents for diana
and then he worked for muhammad mohammed
al-fayed who thought that prince philip
had killed her i mean what sort of world
are you living in ava well i i don't
know i don't i'm not sure about duncan's
point because what you're saying is that
he should have protected diana from the
british press or from the press in
general i don't think your point
actually makes sense you said he should
have been better trained and a better
driver to protect diana from the press
that's what you're saying no no i'm not
okay i'll clarify what i'm actually
saying what i'm actually saying is that
having been a royal editor and and been
involved with covering the roles for
years you know that they were acting i
know i i know
that the the protection officers are not
there to protect diana or a royal from
being photographed she was the most
photographed women in the world what
they are there for is her safety so
driving at high speed to try and get to
that that would never that would never
have been loud can i go back to michael
cobb that would not have been loud
michael can i just
i i'm not trying to a dog with a bone
here
duncan larkin has put his hands in the
air and said that the british press in
whatever guys were partly responsible
why do you refuse to accept uh i don't
understand this i'd love you to explain
to me muhammad al fayed employed the
people the security that looked after
her
there is absolute fact to be said that
whether that's a driver who drove you
around paris or not or you knew
he and his driving and the security
detail that were with her were employed
by the man that i don't know if he still
employs you because you always say that
he's not responding surely he has to
take an iota of responsibility as well
none of that would have happened at all
the
the security was quite adequate the man
was qualified to drive the car
he didn't drive at excessive speed he
was driving at 60 miles an hour
can i ask you a question that might get
me into trouble are you still employed
by muhammad al fired
absolutely not and i haven't been for
many many years but he's a friend of
mine and i feel very sorry for him and
his family i feel very sorry for william
and harry i feel very sorry for the for
all sorts of people but i do think that
i think there's personally look michael
we can all agree to disagree i think
that if the press was sat here in the
guise of duncan arkham saying you know
what we were nothing to do with it
they've taken their share of
responsibility and all the people by the
way who bought those new newspapers and
wanted stuff on the royal family every
single day could be looking at taking
some form of responsibility but i don't
understand we have to finish now but i
don't understand how a man who provided
the driver he just said he didn't get
drunk and didn't drive at high speed and
said you were at the that the inquest
found that he did
i don't understand that do you no they
well
well the quest did find that they did
not
even
the car was not fit for purpose it had
been broken up and put back together uh
in a way which was illegal uh and
frankly speaking he should never have
been in that car with
a prisoner so if we get to the point
michael final word from you if if
muhammad al fired operation employed a
man who was drunk and provided a car
that was not well equipped to you know
because mike said it had been broken up
before how can muhammad alfie we're
going to get an argument because we're
talking about an amazing woman's legacy
but how are they not able to go yes in
part we made a few mistakes here i don't
understand it
none of this would have happened let's
get back to the basics
none of this would have happened if they
hadn't been treated as quarry by
vociferous
unrelenting press intruders throughout
the last day of their lives okay can i
ask you one last question
at all i believe they were in part
responsible your description of the
vociferous press and and how they have
how do you describe the bbc that
employed martin bashir who lied and made
things up and drove diana i would think
in terms of psychology and mental health
uh to a point that she had never been
before what do you say about that
organization
he was disgraceful he was disgraceful
and i've written several articles in the
sunday express
denouncing what he did in great detail
so you are completely wrong there i have
no time for martin bashir and i've told
him so to his face okay michael cole
thank you very much indeed duncan um i
think it would be fair to say the press
were in part responsible i suppose guys
i mean the biggest tragedy is that this
amazing woman who was such an icon and
such a beacon was taken
so soon from her kids and later in the
week we'll talk more we'll talk about
what she would have made of of the the
royal family today her son in california
with with megan um we'll talk more later
in the week about her on the cut um and
also andrew apparently his daughters
over the weekend begging prince charles
to allow their father
um and all that he's been through back
into public life and charles who's
taking millions of quid in old plastic
bags in supermarkets he apparently said
no the royal family today is very
different from when my old man worked
for them but more of that coming up and
next on uncensored this is good imagine
opening your doors to ukrainian refugee
only for them to walk out of those doors
with your partner about three weeks
later we'll meet the woman who did just
that she'll tell us the whole story it's
here it's after the break we're coming
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored my friends
now they say no good deed goes
unpunished and one woman who would say
amen to that is lorna garnet back in may
lorna and partner tony welcomed sophia
carcadim a 22 year old it worker as a
refugee from ukraine and whilst lorna
was no doubt hoping the addition to the
household would settle in nicely she
wasn't expecting it to settle into the
bed next to a partner and the father of
her kids um
this this scheme by the way 25 000
british people signed up for the homes
for ukraine scheme and in total 84 000
ukrainians
moved into hosts
houses 350 pounds a month um first up
lorna thank you so so much for joining
us really really appreciate it um
i don't know where to start
um
just tell us the story whilst i ask the
people in the gallery to turn my ear out
because i can hear them all asking what
they're going to have for dinner uh
lorna
tell me how it happened
yeah
um so basically um anthony was adamant
that we moved in a ukrainian refugee to
help obviously everything that's going
on in the war it's horrendous
so he pleaded with me to go on his side
to help bring in a ukrainian refugee
into our home so i accepted
and ten days later um she's packed her
bags and gone and he's followed behind
her
can i just go back to when you said he
convinced me were you against the idea
was his motivation humanitarian or do
you think his motivation was different
i'm not trying to foresee what was going
to happen but i'm just wondering you you
painted the picture that he was keener
than you why
he
he
he wanted me to accept it because of
what's happened in his past with his
family he because he's told my
background story that he he's got
russian blood basically and his granddad
were rushing
and they fled the cold war so he wanted
to do something good
and obviously if it would happen in our
country then
he'd like to think that someone would be
there to help us but i was i wasn't dead
against it
but i had my worries about it because
obviously we've got a three-year-old and
a six-year-old together and bringing a
stranger into our home around two young
girls i was really funny about it
it's really interesting to from from
afar to have watched uh you know the the
people in the united kingdom show such
tenacity i think and and do that so i
think it shows an awful lot about our
country but yours is one of the the most
talked about stories because as you said
within 10 days
not i mean fast by 10 days what did you
start to suspect what what happened i i
mean 10 days is nothing
it isn't so it was literally day two of
her being here she arrived on the
wednesday by the thursday her appearance
changed
so
she'd gone from wearing baggy clothes to
hair scrunched up to them wearing more
look up tops plastering her face with
makeup
and
he she would always be the first one to
welcome in him
home when he'd walk through the door
saying oh anthony you're home you're
home
um i've made tea and i'll be a bit like
well i've already made him tea you know
but she'd always kind of like drag him
in she'd always be the first one there
to welcome him so that were a bit of a
red flag at first but obviously i
couldn't bring it up with either of them
because
it wasn't such a major concern at that
point
how quickly do you now know they got
together
from even before her arriving
even before
i'm out in the press yeah
yes it's come out he's put in the in one
article i think it's with the sun
and that he'd been talking to a four
month prior
to her arriving in the uk
so
in this scheme that involves 84 000
ukrainians
is there a whiff of the fact that this
bloke
knew and somehow managed to get her to
move in with you guys was this
pre-planned in any way is that how you
now feel
i 100
100 i think it was all done over
facebook of a messenger and he used the
government scheme to help bring her here
oh my lord um one of the things that's
come out obviously recently is is that
a lot of these families who showed such
desire to help and get their 350 pounds
that's not enough i think uh the
refugees minister lord harrington has
called for the money payment to be more
to maybe be doubled because of the
rising cost of living you talk very
honestly about how you believe that he
was doing it out of the kindness of his
heart and then you paint a picture of a
bloke who'd got this planned how does it
leave you feeling because this is the
bit of the story that i really struggle
with because you say
i i have no ill will towards him really
or her
i haven't
basically what's done is done
um
but in the grand scheme of things 350
pound wouldn't have helped at all
because the setup cost obviously with
buying her toiletries feminine products
going out shopping to go buy a new
clothes because she came with very very
little
um i've spent a hell of a lot more than
350 pounds
but but but i'm not i'm not trying to
listen i respect you but i mean you said
i'm looking back i'm happier than i've
ever been
so you weren't happy with him anyway i
am
so you weren't happy with him anyway it
was more
i was happy with him it's his past and
so three years ago he cheated on me um
with his boss from work
we have to become so they will never
that we can't get back together we can't
be specific on that because obviously
there's only one side but i will say
this to you um you say that you hold no
ill will and and that actually this is
extraordinary thing about you is that
you say that you still support the
scheme despite that the heartache it's
brought to you
i do because the way i see it is you
can't tarnish everyone with the same
brush there's good and bad in everybody
out there
and
unluckily for me we picked
a bad egg
um you say about it i do believe that
there's
gone
so i do believe that there's so many
genuine genuine people out there who do
need a roof over the head they do need
the support just to get back on their
feet to find a home
to find themselves a job and live as a
normal human being should i think you're
an amazing woman in an interview with
yorkshire live your ex partner said uh
the couple that's him and his ukrainian
lady are moving to ukraine to help
orphan children all very admirable what
about his own kids
exactly exactly this is my issue at the
minute
in reality some radio station i've never
heard of i was doing the right thing
that i believed i was doing to help
someone that was fleeing a war zone i
was making her feel comfortable silly
things like puffing oh put puffing
pudding ukrainian subtitles it's all
very it's all right but i do i do have
to ask you this because it isn't the
public domain you say you hold no ill
will to her and i really appreciate you
coming on and no ill will think but
you've got a restraining order against
him
i have yes um due to threatening
messages
so that had to be put in place i'll tell
you something i've spoken to a few
people in my time lorna and i have to
say that you are extraordinarily calm
and and and maybe is a is a lesson for
us all actually that whatever we think
is happening at the time when you take
stock
you realize that things weren't great
and maybe all of this however painful
puts you in a better place but what i
really admire about you genuinely is
that you can still which is i think it's
quite a british thing i'll be slagged
off for saying that but i thought the
way that the british
you know people rallied behind this
desire to help ukraine ukrainians quite
rightly was amazing and you're still sat
here saying i do it again which um
which must mean an awful lot to people
watching because it means a lot to me um
i wish you luck moving forward and and i
really um with the kids as well they're
okay and i hope that tony finds
happiness with whatever she's called
sophia um thank you so much lorna i
really appreciate it lorna garnet there
the lady who opened her doors to a
ukrainian refugee and literally 10 days
later he ran off with her what a
balanced and wonderful lady thank you
for being on uncensored right next
running scared a story leadership front
runner liz trust pulls out the scheduled
interview with the bbc's nick robinson i
don't blame her uh saying she doesn't
have time i don't blame her uh good luck
for the soon-to-be prime minister if she
is i don't blame her coming back in
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to justin's journals talk
tv host mike graham is back and
political correspondent ava santina
they're a double up before we go
sorry the lorna you're fascinated by
lorna garnett story are you i mean this
is this is not gonna sound a lot more
horrendous than i meant it but there was
something quite amusing about that
ukrainian woman flaunting her breasts
around the house wearing a low-cut top i
just thought that it's really like
american soap opera isn't it well
there's something and did you get the
feeling that he must have known her
before well i get that definitely got
that vibe i mean it's clearly wrong on
this guy isn't it wrong as she would
have put it had she been kind of
in in that in that mood but i i get the
feeling they knew each other beforehand
and you know for them the war in ukraine
was an opportunity well listen for her i
don't think it's not i reckon he was
talking to hundreds well we can't
obviously
he might not but he might have just
fallen in love with with the fear don't
give it a long time let's put it that
way well you're cynical it could be love
anyway i respect lorna i love and then i
made the point about the kids you know
that that's the most important thing in
all that you and i know that right
now
why are you asking me you two i don't
know i mean he's gonna go off and look
after orphan kids so i just said what
about his ownership exactly can we talk
about artemis nasa calls off new uh moon
rocket launch it's going to cost 93
billion now you're going to both
disagree with me i i'm not a big fan of
space travel because i think we should
actually be spending all the things that
matter in this world like what yeah well
kids hospitals well yeah we do we spend
loads of money in all that as well but
what's wrong we're going up to the space
kids like space right let me let me just
study are they yeah sean the sheep yeah
right sure this team has been assigned a
lucky seat on the 42-day trip into space
first human astronauts will take the
flight in 2025 oh sorry that was the
back of sean the sheep down the front
yeah yeah they're also taking snoopy to
try to check the gravity you'd like to
think they know about gravity before
they go up into space are you a fan of
space i quite like space exploration
yeah ever since neil armstrong the man
who walked on the moon told me to f off
i've had a great relationship with
astronauts yeah i called him up for a
quote on something and he told me to ref
off didn't he what was the quote though
was it do you believe that bbc is
responsible for diana
no it wasn't
a whole circle here today space shuttle
blew up oh right you know um good as
long as you didn't mention never mind uh
liz struss and he said uranus uh liz
trust uh interview she was gonna do an
interview with the bbc that bloated
organization yes she now says she can't
spare the time sunac was interviewed by
nick robinson on the 10th the bbc's
bloated isn't it the bbc's
we don't know we're not a fan of the bbc
so nick robinson is an incredibly rude
interviewer i don't know who he thinks
he is he seems to think that he
represents the entire nation and is the
is the father of democracy he kind of
shouts at politicians it's not the way
to do it that's not how you get
information out of them and he's just
really really rude by himself i wouldn't
do it either i'm quite into that article
this week about emily maitlis lagging
off other bosses at the bbc what's your
view i don't think that's quite what she
was doing i think that she was pointing
out that there was a direct line into
the conservative party in her opinion in
one way or another and i actually was
i experienced that myself not at the bbc
but another organization i remember we
would do certain things and i would get
calls from number 10 directly to my
mobile asking me to take certain things
off so i i have experience for that it's
interesting the critics of the bbc would
say there's a left-wing bias well there
is i mean i don't think you'd have to go
very far if you asked a question of all
presenters on the bbc is whether they
voted leave or remain i think we all
know what they did you can tell by their
faces the night that boris johnson won
in 2019 how upset they were we know what
they're like the point is aleister
campbell was the king of trying to
meddle with bbc politics and he quite
often won and he was in downey street
and he would bring up radio 5 live and
tell him to change the uh the top line
i must be really fast i've never heard
half of these radio stations uh pakistan
on a serious note um one third of the
country tonight shocking scenes is
underwater at least 1200 people now have
died since the monsoon season began um
climate change that's what everybody's
saying what's your view it's a horrible
thing the queen deeply sounded sent a
message as well yeah i mean it's quite
clearly climate change i think what's
interesting is
the same day that this is all you know
going ahead and we're not going to be
sending particularly a lot more funding
um the independent ran a story that
billions more will be cut from our
foreign aid budget and the people who
are suffering are people in pakistan and
instead that money is being diverted to
um re-situate ukrainians into the uk
well i would hope see that the thing is
and i i i know it's you and i would
never agree on this people watching this
who are struggling with the cost of
living however difficult those horrible
horrible scenes are we get the same
thing i was saying earlier about the nhs
where do you prioritize do you do it on
climate change do you do it on more
doctors and nurses do you do it on
better education do you do it on cutting
energy bills what there's only a certain
amount of money it's a horrible choice
at the end of the day you know it's not
our responsibility to help every other
country in the world as noble as that
may well be there's a lot of people
living in this country who have got
pakistani heritage yeah there's a lot of
money in that community you know i would
like to see them stepping up and saying
look our country is underwater now let's
let's start that's what's going on i
mean i look i look at those and i feel
the same as over and you it's horrible
and you want to do your bit but my point
is very we haven't got much time how do
you prioritize you could talk about how
we are prioritizing it and we're
spending that money a lot of that money
on ukraine and not so taking it away we
should take it away but why are we
funneling all of our money into ukraine
and funneling it all into resettling
people here and then ignoring pakistan
i'm sorry but it feels like a race issue
to me
because they're not ignoring pakistan
no we give focus on loads of money what
they trust uh to decide to do with it is
their business they don't obviously
spend it on flood defenses and maybe
they should and maybe the money that we
give them already they could spend
better and at the end of the day you
know we've got
an absolutely wrecked infrastructure we
can't handle our own water
it's very difficult to see those
pictures but i have to say that that for
me that's the point isn't it um people
in this country will say yes but and
you've started saying about ukraine we
talked about war fatigue last week very
quickly uh vma johnny depp disgusting
and clearly desperate said amber heard
sister uh slamming johnny depp of his
mtv appearance what do we think of this
yeah he was on a hologram right he was a
hologram yeah so it was it wasn't even
he was that hologram and he's safer in a
hologram yeah you can't he can't do
anything badly he said he's not there
he's not actually holograms aren't
actually real i understand i'm a
hologram now
he's very fine looking
his first major public appearance since
the defamation trial uh unless of course
he was in newcastle playing at um uh
with jeff because that's another story
yeah you always look at he was frowning
at me and i slightly worried but thank
you very much i'd love to have had them
on a bank holiday you're like you're
like the they never stopped the top duo
are you at it the whole time you're
working all the time ava michael thank
you ever so much i hope you've enjoyed
your bank holiday it's a week until he's
back p.m we'll be back monday week but
we're here tomorrow night that's it from
me don't forget whatever you're up to
tonight make sure you have it and keep
it uncensored have a good one we'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that romaine had won and
at half past two port of three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost but it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor there are
renewed calls for the two tory
leadership candidates to step up their
response to the cost of living crisis a
new poll suggests one in four people in
the uk won't be turning their heating on
this winter because of spiraling energy
bills
around a third of pakistan is currently
under water after devastating floods
across the country more than 1 000
people have been killed the country's
appealing for more help from the
international community
and a 16 year old boy who died at leeds
festival has been described by his
family as a beautiful fiercely
independent and warm character david
celino died in hospital on sunday after
falling ill at the festival the night
before the investigation into his death
is ongoing
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you